bueno no diré que es una retaliación
sino que es una acción natural de un
bloque de países de un continente que no
puede ser excluido de un proceso como un
encuentro continental ya estas
decisiones unilaterales por parte de los
eeuu no caben más en un mundo como el
que vivimos hoy o sea allá y américa
latina se ha levantado vemos el apoyo
del presidente de méxico desde argentina
a los países que han sido excluidos
inclusive por el mismo luis arce de
bolivia diciendo que no participaría en
la cumbre acaso no está en los países no
sean invitados es una forma de natural
de exponer una articulación política que
demuestra una soberanía del continente
hacia una postura injerencista de los
eeuu y que se espera que ocurra en la
reunión en cuba
es una reunión que de alguna forma tiene
también un trasfondo económico no
recordando que venezuela es la mayor
reserva de petróleo del planeta logró
articular en torno de lo que es el alba
casi toda centroamérica y el caribe para
una soberanía energética de esos países
y no depender más
económicamente y también no sucumbir
ante la presión de los eeuu por ejemplo
en momentos de votación dentro del
asamblea desde los estados americanos no
entonces yo creo que en este momento hay
una definición tanto en materia política
de postura hacia el gobierno y baile
pero también de articulación económica
entre estos países que por menores que
seas también tienen son países que votan
en la onu son países que votan en
instituciones multilaterales y que de
alguna manera se demuestran actuando en
bloque para poder ya así posicionarse
internacionalmente ante ese tipo de
medidas y recordemos que el alba nació
en 2004 como un proyecto paralelo para
integrar américa sin la presencia de
estados unidos y especialmente de sus
tratados de libre comercio pero que
tanto se puede avanzar en política y en
economía de la región sin la presencia
de este país y también sin varios
latinoamérica como chile argentina o
brasil o colombia que no hacen parte del
alma
bueno en el mundo en un mundo multipolar
es importante que los países puedan
actuar en bloque cuando cuando existe
una unidad de países que no tienen la
capacidad de negociar
por ejemplo en materia de comercio
exterior con la unión europea con asia o
con los eeuu es mejor trabajar en bloque
imagínate lo que sería un país pequeño
como 'el salvador' negociando sola con
la unión sólo con la unión europea o un
país como uruguay ahora si tú pones a
toda américa latina integrada bajo un
concepto de unidad para permitir mejores
condiciones económicas e inclusive
también posturas políticas
internacionales para defender la
soberanía estos países es muy importante
yo creo que el mundo está cambiando
américa latina también está cambiando
nuevamente se se alinean los movimientos
progresistas con las victorias últimas
victorias electorales y ahora también en
el caso de colombia con el despunte de
gustavo petro que puede ser inclusive
que gane en primera vuelta entonces ese
equilibrio de la región es importante y
el alba ha nacido en 2004 como respuesta
al alca no que era la propuesta del área
de libre comercio de américa era un
proyecto neoliberal
que se cae frente a un proyecto de
inclusión de integración al
latinoamericano con un enfoque hacia
nuestra propia región realmente tiene en
sí y juega un rol importante de
articulación en bloque de países que no
tendrían ningún peso internacional se
actuarían solos entonces es importante
considerar esto en este momento político
de américa latina donde por ejemplo en
el caso de colombia puede ganar gustavo
petro en el caso de brasil puede ganar
el presidente lula boris gana en chile
vuelve luízar se vuelve la izquierda
bolivia gracias a mauri y chamorro por
estar con nosotros en france 24